[Music]
okay in unsuccessful protests news that
just sounds like protests meted by
hole-in-the-wall oh I've seen this I
know we are I know we are I've seen this
before
okay all is very clear a vegan cafe that
charged an 18% man tax is now shutting
down Wow like like I'm like the gender
man or just gender man
so like men just get charged more yep
that's all cuz they're just trying to
say how men and women are just not equal
and like women get paid I knew it the
pay gap oh you can't do that though I'm
pretty sure female strippers get paid
way more than I think so
right I don't know about that I'm pretty
sure I don't think so
really I have two parties be thrown but
it might be more generous poison you
throwing
cash the reporters oh okay so this vegan
cafe in Melbourne Australia see you
would go with some wacky [ __ ] with
homeless people that aren't homeless and
rats that are dogs or whatever all right
so this cafe is called handsome her oh
my god and some her Oh confused already
it sparked debate globally in 2017 when
it announced that they would be they
would offer women priority TV and charge
men and 18% premium to reflect the
gender pay gap that's also all Vegas
clubs - yep girls going for free guys
gotta pay hell welcome to the show
Canada of to see little wait to the game
yeah so after two years they have
announced that they will be closing
their doors
damn faucet two years yeah oh that's
dope yeah it looks dope in there and
some hurt wonder how the food is so it's
vegan well probably that's probably why
- shut down yeah
nothing to do with anything but the fact
but look good doesn't mean tastes good
true so do you like do you just and not
pip I don't think you tippin's now in
that way you'd be saving 2% yeah that's
true
oh but you don't tip in Austria yeah
it's all it's all included so let me
show you guys a video clip really quick
and I can't around a little bit this
cafe one week out of every month we have
an 18% premium from men which is the
same amount as the gender pay gap I
think it's fair if you think about the
world and the gender and equality that
we have that many people know where am i
oh it's only a week out of the month oh
that's not bad it's not mandatory
oh they're just trying to make a point I
think like a lot of when food places try
to get to political political and we're
like civil with their [ __ ] and like I
said in protests it didn't work that's
wrong same file a minute violet in the
drawer just make delicious food you know
needs kind of protest like word counts
go to city government do all that [ __ ]
and I don't know that's like mixing the
two together there's always like a
well-known thing to like when you when
you share a big you're not supposed to
talk about religion and politics and
other to share that when you kind of mix
those right because food is I always saw
food as a way to break down all those
things yes these dreams you bring the
tension regular food I don't know yeah
what are you peace maker ice makers
Socrates keepers
keeps trying to make fun of them cuz in
high school you had a peacemakers group
where they would beat up people good you
guys are vigilantes huh where did you
Boy Scout leader come any of that he was
like the The Master Splinter hunt the
Turtles yeah come over pizza in the
sewers we be today who we'd beaten off
today Keepers 18% man tax oh that's
crazy
yeah so they didn't mention exactly why
they're going out of it the food they
don't imagine any reason there's a
pretty big I guess like talk or debate
about the whole pig thing I thought we
all knew that it existed I mean it's
been a debate thing since forever but a
lot of the reasons why at the highest
levels females don't have the same or
the quota is not the same is because
women have to choose either being a
mother or being a CEO they can't do both
what do you mean the quotas not the same
oh well there's a there's a disparity
right in the working from other words
there's a disparity because there's more
men making more money yeah because when
you know like when it comes to that age
when a girls actually when a female's up
it is is rising up the corporate ladder
she has to make a choice in her 30s in
like oh [ __ ] and that's when you make
your you know that's when you start to
really get into your careers in your 30s
and then you could either go up and
become an executive or all those things
but a lot of women choose to become a
mother so then they pull out of the work
place and then they start to raise
families so that's why there's a huge
gap because they don't they don't pass
that stage yeah well where does this pay
gap because if you if you round the
numbers up yeah if women only go up to
30 and then they don't they don't push
that bar yeah then you have guys in
their 40s and 50s and all that that are
like still climbing up the corporate
ladder without taking any breaks so then
they make more money
whereas ladies like they might take a
break raise kids and then they might go
back to the workplace or you know they
might try to do both but then they can't
really focus a hundred is that really
what it is
yeah it was something else I thought
like literally men made
because no that's because of them yeah
the paint gap the pay gap is because of
a huge part of it is that kind of makes
yeah that's no interesting because like
I could see that because Mariel was
talking about how when she made a career
flip and a lot of the women in her
company that she worked for that she
looked up to that were above a lot of
the men yeah in terms of like
coordinating a producing no kids no kids
you can't yeah so she was looking man
it's [ __ ] water yeah and they were
talking you know she had conversations
with them to is she goes you can't do
this well you know what also sucks
though and this is part of the
prejudiced part is we're like if it's
now a man and a woman versus the exact
same job and they're both equally
qualified I don't that's harder right
for sure the one that's easier on the
eyes maybe man woman unless the Koala
gettin paid is Australia we got to think
about that when is it happening is the
guys gonna or the boss is gonna go for
the guy because of that like maternity
leave you know and that's [ __ ] up
because it's statistically women in
their 20s or actually surpassing men in
the workplace
higher pays at this if you if you go
like age for age right but then at a
certain point there's a shift and then
guys just stay in it so if you stay in
your work line of work and you don't
leave do you have a tendency to get paid
higher it just I mean it just makes
sense that way right so like let's say
you never left a job you've been in the
county and you keep staying you grow in
the company you don't take any breaks
and then eventually you're gonna get to
the top and but then you know a lot of
females will want to have a family and
then they'll leave the workplace or
maybe they they have to do it part-time
and all that stuff so they get stopped
at a certain level so that's that's the
majority of the statistic and if we talk
about CEOs like I think even in men
that's very low because it's hardest
book to be at that yeah I mean we were
all in business and we know what it
takes to be a top dog it's [ __ ] nuts
not saying that women can't do it but
there's a lot of what do you call it
Psychopaths
in that genetic trait I think is
inherent in men more than females the
type of person that that can be one yeah
yeah how do you make a living done I was
trying to stay silent this entire time I
feel like there's a lot of landmines
here and I'm just no let's hear you
we're not women I have my foot on one
right now and if I move oh it's gonna
blow up
no that's not the space bro okay you're
good so what I'm hearing is the cafe is
accurate because you can choose to make
more money yeah or you can choose to eat
at a different [ __ ] cafe yep and
people chose the latter to eat a
different cafe was clearly a plant very
[ __ ] schematics great the cafe
whatever we eat now yeah okay I might
you know 18% really he didn't know what
was going on he came to use the bathroom
80% pig-out well you know what was going
on black burger vegan black burger
I want a charcoal vegan black burger if
a restaurant is [ __ ] Bombo it doesn't
[ __ ] matter I will play it open so
yeah guarantee you is probably because
the food was just winner yeah it doesn't
sound like no if I mean I've never tried
it so I can't say I'll say it wasn't
that good all right I can offend the
food I just maybe but what if you get an
18% charge though and then it says man
tax on your receipt what would you do
what if they're proud about it this is
the man tax and they go oh but you don't
have to pay I'm like you should have
never said this is an odd sense of pride
no or they're like charging you more to
be there like yeah yeah yeah yeah give
me that tag cause you think you could
they're like they know you could afford
it oh no I just for some reason I by
instinct just says yes man tax just
[ __ ] tax me I'm a [ __ ] man
what pinna be behind that is your you're
also punishing somebody for they didn't
have a choice to be born as a man and
now you're punishing them for being born
something that they didn't have a choice
in you know and they're like what the
[ __ ] you know that's basically saying
you make more you should be able to pay
more is the statement I think man if I
saw it I'll be like damn Australia got
some [ __ ] up laws man and I just pay
it because I thought I would think it's
the law of Australia mm-hmm nah she
wouldn't let you pay that [ __ ] I'll pay
then you could pay me back and this
you'll pay yeah way to make money off
this I'm sure the man tax there's a scam
somewhere in here there's gotta be I
like where your mind is going this this
is why men make more money scam tax
we're gonna do dirty that's true women
are too honorable that's the thing they
follow the rules too much break it a
little bit and then you'll make more
money I've seen a lot of movies about
the women scammers honest well there's
that new ocean I saw that one but that's
stealing right that's not scanning and
it still feels like a copy of Ocean's
eleven it also feels like the guys with
them were the bad guys guys were bad
because